hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain an american drama fantasy and
thriller movie called life changer
the movie starts by showing a woman
waking up in a hotel room her name is
emily it is very strange that there is a
dry corpse beside her that looks similar
to her knowing what to do she chops the
dead body into pieces and puts them into
the garbage bags
afterwards she brings the garbage bags
into someone's barn and burns them down
she also buries the ash into a hole
after a while she goes to a cafe
strangely she practices to introduce
herself and also learns about herself
after that she returns to her home where
her boyfriend has been waiting for her
to come home recently while she is
smoking in the living room her boyfriend
james suddenly approaches her he then
asks where she has been going all this
time
thus he called the police to find her
whereabouts when he wants to call the
police emily immediately kills him
without feeling guilty she erases all
the evidence of her murder just now
she also wraps james's body and hides it
in the basement
after everything is finished she takes
antibiotics for her unknown disease
the next day she is worried because her
body begins to rot
she does not expect her body to rot so
quickly
later the detective hired by her
boyfriend comes to her house
his name is renzone he is initially
surprised seeing that emily was already
at home
he also wants to meet with james but
emily replies that he was not with her
she then invites him to chat in the
living room when she sits beside renzon
she suddenly holds his hand tightly
a few minutes later renzone's body
becomes a dry corpse as emily has turned
into red zone to get rid of the evidence
again he breaks the dry corpse with a
hammer he also pours the gasoline around
his house to set it on fire at the front
door he meets with a delivery man who
brings the food that was ordered by him
earlier the man also warns him that his
house is on fire but renzon chooses to
ignore him and immediately leaves the
place with his police car
on his way he realizes that he has to
rely on antibiotics and cocaine to delay
the rotting in his body
he then stops by a drug dealer and
decides to buy some cocaine for himself
later a few hours later it turns out
that he wants to go to a bar to meet
someone else
arriving there he is greeted by a dog as
if they were old friends
he then enters the bar to find the
person
after searching around he finally finds
the woman sitting alone at the bar
he immediately sits beside her and
orders a gin asking the woman if she
wants one
at first she is surprised that renzo
knows her only favorite drink at the bar
after introducing themselves it is known
that the woman's name is julia she asks
how he knows her favorite drink and he
replies that maybe he guessed it by
chance
at the end they both spend all night
talking and drinking together but when
they are kissing outside the bar renson
suddenly feels pain in his stomach
because of that he asks julia to leave
him alone knowing that his body begins
to rot
fortunately he manages to leave the
place alone
not far from there he sees a couple
talking inside a car
he then orders the woman to get out of
the car using his police badge
he sits inside the car and tells the
middle-aged man named sam that he has to
kill him or he will die later
hearing this sam tries to fight back but
his efforts are in vain
sometime later it is known that renzon
has turned into sam
he then destroys the dry corpse using a
hammer before it is burned completely
suddenly his wife mary calls him to come
home when he gets home it can be seen
that they don't seem to get along
indicating an unhappy relationship
the next morning he is woken up by her
daughter because he is late for work
it turns out that he still feels the
pain in his stomach just like what he
experienced before
he also refuses to join them for
breakfast lying to them that he has
urgent work
arriving at work he talks with one of
the receptionists there named rachel
she is also the woman who was in the car
with him last night
looks like they are having an affair
then sam continues his work as a dentist
as usual
when having lunch at a restaurant he
sees julia returning home alone
he quickly gets into a taxi and asks the
driver to follow julia's car but sadly
the driver does not want to because she
thinks that stalking is not true
therefore he decides to go to the cinema
and watches the film alone that night he
is dinner with his family but he looks
unhappy at the same time
he seems to be thinking about his past
before he changed from one body to
another over the years furthermore he
visits the same bar where julia is
located he knows that julia always comes
to that bar every night not long after
julia sits next to him and says that she
saw him the night before with a young
woman
from that time she admits that her
marriage is not going well
she reveals that she was already married
and had a son but unfortunately her son
died when he was three years old because
of his severe illness straining her
relationship with her husband from that
time
she also continues that one night her
husband prepared a romantic dinner for
them
she thought that it was the perfect
moment for them to make things up
beforehand
but strangely after the good time they
had her husband disappeared without a
trace
since then she has never seen her
husband until now meanwhile sam tries to
comfort her by buying her another drink
after that he goes to the toilet and
sees that his body begins to rot as a
result he says goodbye to julia and
decides to go to a motel for the night
arriving there he inhales the cocaine
realizing that his body is getting worse
in other words he has to find another
host to survive as soon as possible with
his brilliant idea he calls rachel to
come to his place saying that he is
unwell a few moments later rachel
arrives at his place
she is confused when she sees sam lying
on the bed and does not react even
though she calls his name many times
she then slowly touches sam's body
just like before now sam has turned into
rachel's body she immediately takes the
antibiotics again
the following day she burns the corpse
in the exact same barn as emily did
earlier but this time she is almost
caught by a woman around
she immediately leaves the place and
heads to her workplace to get some
antibiotics for herself hoping that her
body can last longer
that night she returns to the same bar
and directly approaches julia again
this time julia recognizes her as the
woman who was with sam a few nights
before
they both share their stories happily
until julia gives rachel her card so she
can find and talk to her anytime
shortly after a man tries to flirt with
rachel but she decides to ignore him as
her eyes are still on julia who meets up
with an artist man at another table
however she accidentally sees her face
on the tv as a suspected barn smuggler
she immediately asks the man to take her
away from that place to his apartment
they are eventually having fun together
until the man gets high and turns
aggressively at her because of that she
fights him back and ends up stabbing him
to death
outside she quickly runs away from that
place as the police arrive at the
building
she manages to hide in an abandoned
garage and spends the night in there
the next day she finds out that her body
begins to rot
she decides to spy on julia and the man
in the bar last night when they both
want to return to their respective homes
rachel follows the man into his home
feeling jealous she intends to take the
man's body his name is robert
after that he calls julia to confess his
feelings all along and wants to see her
again tonight
soon they have a romantic date at
julia's house they end up falling in
love with each other eventually sleeping
together at night which is the only
moment he is looking forward to the most
one morning julia sees the news on the
tv about a serial murder that is still
mysterious until now
robert suddenly comes and changes the
news immediately because he doesn't want
her to watch depressing news like this
unluckily later he sees another blister
on his hand and starts to feel the pain
in his stomach
desperately he walks out from the
bathroom and decides to confess
everything to julia he tells her that
actually he is true at first he does not
know how to explain himself to her even
he doesn't know what he is
the only thing he knows is he
unintentionally took over his mother's
body consequently killing her and got
all the memories of her life in 1954
every time he takes over someone's life
he also gets their memories
since then he only had two choices kill
or die
on the other hand julia thinks that the
whole story was [ __ ] to convince her
even more he reveals that julia's
husband who abandoned her in the past
was actually himself
even though he turns into someone else
continuously he says that he will always
love her forever because julia is
freaked out about all of this she grabs
a taser and attacks him until he falls
off to the floor
therefore he holds julia's hands to stop
her but then he accidentally takes her
body at the end drew who is now turned
into julia weeps over her dead body
regretting what he has done just now
a few days later drew desperately
accepts his fate and bids his time to
die
strangely enough he is instead reborn in
the form of a gray-haired old man and
then continues his life freely subscribe
to watch more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching
[Music]